so you mentioned
roger bannister again i think in your
first book
somebody you looked up to that's the man
who broke the four-minute mile
right when everybody said it was
impossible
everyone thought it was impossible
sometimes you would die it would die
it's not
human it's not human yeah so what
well you've done your homework for what
the book or what i don't know for me
you've done your homework yeah i know
but yeah uh
sent here by putin to do research yeah
so what
lesson do you take from that story for
yourself the impossible
trying to accomplish the impossible well
the impossible is possible
it's just that simple time changes
things
i mean i mean if you look at what
where the mile time is right now
compared to that four minute mile
which when it was broke by a couple
tenths or three or four tenths
it's now broke by uh another 20 seconds
yeah i mean by 700 people yeah yeah i
mean
by tons of people and it's pretty much
the common knowledge that you got to run
a four minute mile if you're going to go
somewhere now
or or below if you're going to win win
events
at major level that you got to be able
to do that and so
you can take that and you can look at
what
in time history has as its
record performance and you can realize
that
that record performance is going to
change yeah
and and they don't take into all the
factors of knowledge
they don't take in all the factors of
better shoes
they don't take in all the factors of
better understanding and nutrition
i mean it's like me as an athlete
i went to practice every day in high
school for
at least my sophomore in my junior and
part of my
senior year and all of a sudden a new
rule came
up i said the rules said um
before that said oh yeah
at least most of the coaches uh you
we don't want you drinking water at
practice yeah and
and okay why because you got to toughen
you up
that's a weakness water and so we would
go through practice
i mean and you're sweating and then
you're sweating so much that
you're almost out of sweat yeah and so
you're mostly at the end of practice
you're not even wrestling
excuse me you're you're sitting against
the wall yeah because you're tired
so then all of a sudden they say okay
go ahead drink water during practice
bring greater adrenaline practice and
all of a sudden
at the end of practice we're still out
there competing and so
i look at my career for two and a half
years where i end with junior high too
so i got another three years where i
didn't really
wasn't able to push as good as i could
because i just
was probably under under-hydrated yeah
you